here's Wikipedia's definition of gays
against groomers is an American
far-right
anti-lgbt organization known for
protesting against gender affirming care
for minors including including at
hospitals that provided against LGBT
representation at schools and against
drag queen Story Hour event some people
may say these are good things uh if you
call that far right you take that far
right out many parents would say these
are things I'm concerned about
a spokesperson for the LGBT advocacy
group glad has claimed that the group
uses the slore groomer to characterize
LGBT people as pedophiles gag has hosted
anti-lgbtq rallies alongside other
far-right and
anti-lgbtq organizations such as moms
for Liberty which has been attended by
proud boys and then it goes into
explaining how Jamie Mitchell started it
who before what she did and how it led
to Libs of tick tock and those videos
went viral etc etc having said that
thank you for being on the podcast thank
you for having me from your perspective
what does gays against groomers do yeah
so we're a coalition of gay people that
do not stand for the sexualization
medicalization or indoctrination of
children through the LGBT umbrella and
for instance Wikipedia likes to you know
preference that using the word groomer
is an anti-lgbtq slur and I would argue
regardless of what your sexuality is
anyone can be a groomer and so we're
targeting all of the things that are
happening with within our community that
damages children and that's going to be
like drag queen Story Hour which is
hypersexualized content in front of
children we're also pushing back against
gender ideology which is forces children
to go down a journey of chemical
castration or seeking out surgeries to
do these types of things to affirm these
genders that they feel like our
organization spends a heavy amount a
heavy excuse me a heavy amount of time
educating the public with information
sessions attending school board meetings
City Council meetings we have our voices
heard in federal legislatures and state
legislation and to be able to combat a
lot of these things our organization is
filled with so many people that have the
same vision for our community wanting to
be accountable for the things that our
community is doing and fixing it which
is why all of us identify or fall under
the LGBT umbrella so being anti
ourselves is never something that uh is
in our mission our mission is to save
children from the indoctrination that's
happening through our umbrella that's
pretty well I brought obviously we have
Jed here from the great Jedediah Billa
live show and we got a Biz Doc in the
house as well uh both of your parents
you have uh Hartley you got Balian broke
I got my set of kids as well this is
something that's very important to all
of us as parents it is a concern I do
want to play this clip of what got my
attention of what you were talking about
and some of you who follow the podcast
closely you saw this clip a couple
months back if you want to play this
maybe the first two minutes will be
great
every teacher that has a pride flag in
their classroom should be fired and
arrested the gay flag is a sexual flag
it represents nothing other than sexual
things gay lesbian bisexual transgender
and questioning what business is it of
anyone on this board of what children
would like to do with other children
it is none of your business it is
between them and their parents but
however you guys want to illegally
survey your students my name is Frank
Rodriguez I'm the executive director of
operations for gays against groomers I'm
a 31 year old gay man pushing back
against the agenda that's happening
within our classrooms
parents away from this discussion is
absolutely severing the relationship
between a child and their parent
my community is not discriminated
against anymore shockingly enough we
succeeded
now you're sending out surveys that's
asking students what their gender is
what their pronouns are and whether or
not you should be telling their parents
do you imagine
if my son or one of yours went to school
and said hey I'm gay and you never knew
all of you up here are pretty
intelligent
you have Doctorate Degrees you're
educated and you lead this District
but yet you turn a blind eye with the
sexual things that happen in your
classroom I refuse to believe that any
of you think that that's appropriate
because if you think that that is
appropriate
you would be a predator
there's images that are going to be
displayed today for you to see of a
child sucking another child off
and that's in your classrooms
I shake because it makes me
uncomfortable to eat and utter those
words to you this is nothing about
inclusion it is nothing about respect to
my community
I stay with you with a hundred percent
truth according to the center of Disease
Control that the reason my community
faces such issues in this world has
absolutely nothing to do with the
straight people on this planet has
everything to do with the drugs that we
digest has everything to do with our
Access to Health Care the number one
reason my community has so many mental
health issues is because they don't have
access to health care and that's the
that's directly from the CDC it is not
slurs it's not gay bashing if we don't
have access to therapy
if you really want to help the lgbtq
community to feel really accepted in
this world
Embrace that people have mental health
issues and they should seek help
having a classroom without the American
flag in it is a disgrace to this country
if this country wasn't here millions of
people around the world would perish
and that flag this flag
should be held high by every single
student so question when you gave that
speech I saw it I couldn't believe it
um you can always judge you know who is
an enemy based on who reacts to this and
who pushes back and saying I can't
believe he said this what a speech this
is ridiculous he's such a this he's such
a that who push back on your speech who
came back and said crank you don't know
what you're talking about
so the main people that push back
against this was going to be my
community the LGBT community they're
very vocal in this the the far left when
it comes to these types of things though
the woke side of this and then also a
lot of um woke women also uh pushed back
on this I think when it comes to my
community you know the gay community
when we point out these things that
really need help such as our mental
health issues or our drug addiction
rates no one wants to talk about these
things they want to brush those under
the rug but the moment you get someone
like Huntington Beach wanting to just
fly the American flag at their
facilities they get uproar they get
angry they get mad but no one fights for
the things that we actually need and so
that's why I'm really glad that this
speech that I say that shook the world
actually opened the eyes to a lot of
people because there are things that my
community needs and unfortunately
they're pushing back on it Jed your
reaction when you're hearing something
like this as a parent what are your
thoughts about this yeah as a parent and
somebody who used to work in schools
um you know this is a to me a deeply
anti-parental rights movement and the
school really wants to get in the way of
the relationship between parents and
their children and you have guidance
counselors now I'm sure you know that
are being told by Administration keep it
confidential don't make phone calls home
to parents you need to make sure these
kids are protected and they present it
as a guide of protection essentially
against their own parents so you have
kids being turned against their parents
in many respects and they feel like the
parents are the enemy they no longer
speak to their parents it breaks down
the lines of communication which
essentially enables you know
indoctrination on many levels then then
you have students in oftentimes
left-wing institutions they're not
communicating with their parents and
larger issues begin to you know be
received in terms of the indoctrination
that we see in schools I think it's
interesting though when I heard you talk
about the American flag that had to be
such an enormous trigger for these
people because a lot of the people who
are battling against what you're doing
are are also battling what this country
represents you know everything this
country represents and I think them
hearing you say that about the American
flag the response the trigger reaction
is well there's people who don't like
the American flag so you know what is
your point about those people that you
know should why can't we take the
American flag down why is the American
flag held to a different standard than
an lgbtq flag so I'm sure that they felt
incredibly triggered by that remark
because not only that do they have a
deep resentment of this country and a
deep resentment of everything it stands
for but they want to correlate what
you're uh what you're saying is true a
sexual a representation of sexuality and
a representation of just this country
the values of Liberty the values of
freedom and whatnot so I think that's I
think that's where you drove these
people to Insanity just the reference of
the American flag itself will make them
nuts so and thanks for doing what you're
doing because you know if nothing else
you're speaking out and it's I'm sure
you get I can't even imagine what comes
your way from the world community so
good for you man thank you you know I'm
I'm looking at this article what is
sexual grooming this is an article from
2017. I don't know if you have this or
not it's not a newer article uh it's uh
six years old seven things to know about
this abuse tactic okay number one anyone
can be a victim okay it often starts
with friendship got it perpetrators use
favors and Promises to build trust make
sense
five grooming can be difficult to
distinguish I'm sorry secrecy is a
common characteristic of grooming which
is number four number five is grooming
can be difficult to distinguish from
romance victims can get out family
members and friends can help but it's
important for them to tread uh carefully
so this this comment this topic of
grooming I watch Vice to the documentary
they did two weeks ago I don't know if
you saw that or not from a couple weeks
ago when it came out did you see the the
I don't think so okay it's not really a
documentary it's just a clip they put on
their Channel if you can go to it I just
send it to you on your uh yeah right
there so this whole thing that came out
to uh transphobic influencers are
driving a violent groomer conspiracy
okay so we don't need to play this clip
but if you play it you guys are in it
you know uh Matt Walsh is in it Rogan's
in it a lot of people are in it that
they're pushing back I'm sure you saw
this Jed on what they're doing okay so
the the argument of this video is there
is no such thing as groomers
okay cool no problem now play what just
came out from Project Veritas that one
you can actually play from two days ago
which I'm sure you guys have seen if
you've not seen it this is from two days
ago okay and this is what parents are
concerned about right when this uh
Reverend I think is called the Reverend
of uh what is the organization called I
think it's called the um it's out in
California
Landslide something something you know
Rabbi texted it to you if you want to
look at it uh it's an Instagram video it
says breaking groomers Reverend Casey
Martinez you know how they do what they
do if you just look at your text you'll
see that I send it to you Loomis Basin
Congregation of the United Church of
Christ Casey Martinez tinnin uh that's
the guy who was very disturbing to see
what this guy's saying in the interview
do you see it I'll just put a thumbs up
so you see it
um I think I texted you like literally 8
39 if you look up 839 send it to you
write that put a thumbs up on it
and you see have you have you taken a
look at the same every year time or no
no
I want you to listen to this if you can
zoom in a little bit so the audience can
see it there you go and refresh it so we
can watch it from the beginning
perfect
there we go audio
in my mind how communities
so I am try to refresh and get the audio
at the same time and pause it so I can
just read the just press the button so
it doesn't play I know we're like this
close to having parents freaking the F
out is how he opens it up then play it
to having parents freaking
in my mind
so I am the older queer folks are
mentoring these young adults I'd be
cocktails about people have you been
have you considered blockers
get them when they're young political we
used to meet at the church because it
was free
and kids would say they're going to
YouTube if we moved to the library
because kids said they were meeting
their friends at the library so it's not
lying but it's not fully the truth when
they know that they're queer kid is
coming to me for support they're going
to be done it's when you are purposely
misgendering them when you are purposely
not using their name how do you handle
that I call it CPS but that's your
standard protocol
if we want these kids to thrive and
survive we must get to their parents
place meet Reverend Casey tennen of
Loomis Basin Congregational Church in
Loomis California Casey is also the
founder of the landing spot a non-profit
Community Center meant to create quote a
safe supportive and empowering space for
lgbtqia plus Youth and their families a
project
it's it's stuff like this that parents
see and and vice one minute is saying no
one's doing this the award conspiracies
it's a conspiracy theorist groomers all
this other stuff then you see this and
they say Okay Vice why don't you now do
something like project Veritas is doing
and really find out for us from both
sides whether this is happening or not
what's your reaction when you see
something like this groomings happen in
many forms it's not just sexual grooming
when you think of grooming anytime you
take a child away from a parent and
teach them something that it goes
against the parents beliefs you are
grooming that child into your ideologies
your beliefs in the way that you want
that child to be regardless if that's
going to be sexual religious or any
other political ways that you think that
that child should be grooming is
happening in so many different
capacities and that's why gays against
groomers is making such Headway in this
because we're breaking barriers and
destroying narratives that the woke
agenda has formed to be able to
Captivate to captive these children
against their parents like we were
saying early earlier if a child if like
in this video where they say that you
know children might you know commit
suicidality or something like that
I mean parents involved in that child's
experience from day one from when
they're born until the parents are gone
is vital to the success of that person
and that's vital for for my community if
we don't have our parents involved in
the decisions that we're making you're
setting up that child to have 40 hired
at drug addiction rates 25 to be able to
commit suicide and just going down a
journey that is not supported
on their own they need their parents and
so like this video saying he can't go to
the parents that's deeply disturbing
because if a child has questions about
who they are or the journey they want to
take in their life the number one people
that can handle this conversation are
the parents I mean they can't
indoctrinate the kids though unless they
remove the parents it's integral so I
mean what that guy saying sitting and
saying a reverence no less sitting and
incur outright encouraging lying saying
you know lie to your parents he says
well it's not lying but of course it's
lying and saying that he's going to call
Child Protective Services on parents for
misgendering the kids I mean he's now
making a decision he's deciding to play
parent he's removed those parents from
the equation he said you don't matter
you're a hazard to your own children
he's made that decision and now he said
well I'm going to do a better job the
state essentially is going to do a
better job of raising your kids than you
are and it's such an integral step
because if you had parents involved you
would have pushback so what's in
interesting is that for years we've had
indoctrination of kids years and years
and years and that you're right that has
been grooming and you know a lot of
conservatives have pushed back on that
for years but something different
happened here when it applied to this
stuff related to sexuality that word
groomer because that word was used
before we've been using I've been using
that word oh they're grooming kids in
schools for years but there wasn't this
type of pushback why do you think now
when it came to sexuality why why such a
pushback to the point where you've
gotten banned I'm sure we'll talk about
that where that word was banned on
Twitter where you couldn't talk about
something there is something deeply
Sinister going on with this agenda as it
relates to children and I don't know if
there's a lot of money to be made by
Pharma I don't know if a lot of
Institutions are connected but there's
something different going on that goes
above and beyond just traditional
indoctrination in schools that they are
responding to you the way that they are
what do you think that is yeah so I talk
about this a lot in my community you
kind of see it from this gentleman here
who obviously is gay a the generate or
the time that we grew up there was
definitely a time where we were
suppressed we were you know attacked for
just simply being who we were and I'm a
firm believer that a majority of my
community has not overcome that closet
trauma and now they're projecting that
onto these kids and they're suffering
the consequences of this and so you see
that in the statistics like you know 60
of my community not getting access to
mental health care and so pairing that
with what we're seeing today a lot of
the people like this gentleman here I
hate to say is probably dealing with
some sort of mental health issue that he
has not overcome and now we're
projecting this on this onto kids as if
it's going to help them and it's not
we're seeing damage we're seeing kids
you know uh seeking out gender affirming
surgeries and coming back and saying
that they don't want to transition
because of behaviors like this so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]